[Music]
I'm so bored of living I wake up every
morning in the same bed I get dressed
and I eat the same breakfast and then
take the same commute to work I'm 28
years old and I'm terrified this is all
there is is this a dream well partly I
know two weeks is a long time for me to
be away if you're feeling weird about
anything just come talk to me and we'll
figure it out you don't need to worry
about me because I'm pretty much okay
pretty much you're fine right I just
feel like everyone's messing with me
they're acting even stranger than usual
you usually act even stranger than usual
but since the accident you have been
acting more even stranger than usual
then usual I'm seeing my dead father I
wasn't in an accident I was killed and
he's training me to travel in time with
your ability we can change what happened
so I can save him from being murdered
you push it yourself too hard keep doing
me I can't do this
I can't keep ending up places though
seeing stops and missing things it's all
about your emotions you need to feel
them without letting them become you how
do I do that just deep breaths hey
babycakes
streams of lifetime's of suffering our
carried through minded body
even the good feelings you have to let
go of those too
that can't be who you are if you want to
be free of course the only one of my
family who believes in me is the dead
one for now
[Music]
[Music]